[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم في النقاش ويمكنكم كالعاده ان
تتفاعل مع ما يقولو في البرنامج على
صفحتنا على فيسبوك او على صفحه البرنامج
على تويتر
على الانتخابات النصفيه في الولايات
المتحده انتخابات لم يكسبها خلال سنوات
الاخيره سيوا جورج بوش الابن
ان يخسر الرئيس الرهان البرلماني بعد
سنتين من دخوله الى البيت الابيض ولكن هل
نبالغ عندما نسال ان كانت الديمقراطيه
الامريكيه في خطر من يشك في انقسام
المجتمع الامريكي منذ ان حكم ترامب
الولايات المتحده الظروف الحاليه زادت من
نظريه المؤامره اكثر من 300 مرشح من الحزب
الجمهوري ليسوا على استعداد للاعتراف
بخسارته في الانتخابات الالاف من الذين
يعتقدون حتى الان ان ترامب هو الذي فاز في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه همم
يسيرون مراكز اقتراع التهديدات التي
يتلقاها النواب الكونجرس ارتفعت عشر مرات
عن ما كانت عليه قبل خمس سنوات فكيف ستكون
مباراه العوده بين بيدن وترامب هذه المره
وفي هذه الاجواء والنظر الى حجم التضخم
كيف يمكن لديمقراطيين تجنب الهزيمه سعيد
بان يناقش الموضوع ومعي من واشنطن هبه
القدس مديره مكتب جريده الشرق الاوسط سعيد
بان يكون معي كما النعواش ومحامي وعضو في
الحزب الجمهوري وسعيد بان يكون معي من
شيكاغو نادر الغول وهو صحفي وباحث سيسي
اهلا وسهلا بكم نبدا ونستمع لما قاله جو
بايت
نحن اليوم امام لحظه محوريه لها اهميه
بالغه للاجيال القادمه
اليوم بخطر وقد حان الوقت لكي ندافع عنها
ونحافظ عليها ونحمها
اريدكم اننا سنكون على قدر المسؤوليه
السلطه في امريكا توجد اليوم حيثما طالما
وجدت اي بين اياديكم ايادي الشعب
امريكا
في عام 2024 سنستعيد البيت الابيض الرائع
وايت هاوس
هبه القدس ليست المره الاولى التي تشاركين
فيها في النقاش لانه عود وذكر بانه برنامج
تفاعلي ابتسامتك المعتاده دليل بانك فهمت
ماذا اقصد اذا هابدا معك هل هناك مبالغه
في وسائل الاعلام الفرنسيه والبريطانيه
وحتى الامريكيه عندما نتحدث بان
الديمقراطيه الامريكيه في خطر اليوم
همم في حريه الراي وحريه التعبير وحريه
التظاهر وما يتعلق ايضا بنجازات
الانتخابات الذي يعني وهو القضيه التي
فاخر بها السياسيون الامريكيين
الان اصبحت الخلافات السياسيه الحزبيه هي
العنصر الشاغل لكل مرشح داخل الامريكي كيف
يروض
تزوير الانتخابات
يعني يصدق الجماهير او الشعب الامريكي
جزءا جانبا كبيرا منه هذه الادعاءات في
الوقت نفسه يرفض القضاء الامريكي
والدعوه القضائيه التي رفعها الرئيس ترامب
في عقاب اعلان النتيجه فنحن امام تقويض
لنزاهه الانتخابات تشكيل في العمليه
الانتخابيه برمتها تشكيك ايضا في
استقلاليه القضاء تشكيله في الاهداف التي
يسعى كل حزب الى تحقيقها في
السلطه التشريعيه في البلاد المساله ليست
خناقه او ليست شاب عمليه شد احد من يجر
الاخر الى مستنقع او من يوقع الاخر في
العراقيين والمشاكل وانما المبدا الاساسي
في عمل شارع الامريكي هو خدمه من من
انتخبوه لكن المساله الان اصبحت ان المشرع
سواء على الجانب الجمهوري او على الجانب
قديم يسال لتحقيق ما يريد التيار المهيمن
على الحزام سواء بالتركيز على ان هناك
عمليات او بعرقله اي تشريعات قد تؤدي الى
استفاده النسب الامريكي وبالتالي الوضع
الاقتصادي سيئ الوضع القيم
الاجتماعيه
والقيم
الديمقراطيه في خطر ايضا طيب جمال انا
عواش يعني دائما الانظار سوف ترامب
باعتبار انه هو السبب في ذلك ورما بكل
ثقاله في هذه الحمله وبالتالي هناك مخاوف
على الاقل هذا من نسمعه ونقراه
نو بصراحه في مبالغات كثير هون اول شيء
خليني اجاوب على سؤالك الاول ما في اي خطر
نهائي لا الديمقراطيه في امريكا هذا الحكي
اللي بنسمع من بايدين يوم بحكي في خطر وبس
في اكمن واحد بيحكي هذا الحكي بس عشان
يحاولوا يشجعوا يشجعوا
الجمهوري قصدي الديمقراطيين يطلعوا يصوتوا
وبعدين
والديمقراطين ميتين من الخوف بالوقت
الحاضر لانه الناس متذايقه كثير همم ماديا
في امريكا الغلى كثير من كل شيء من الاكل
للبنزين للايجار للعقار والشعب الامريكي
متذايق وبغذي النظر انه الحق على بادن ولا
الحق على واحد ثاني ولا على كورونا الشعب
الامريكي
عاده بدون
بدون الرئيس بالوقت الحاضر يوم اشي سيء
يصير سو لو لو بعد ما الى علاقه
بالاقتصاد السيء اللي بالوقت الحاضر في
امريكا والغلا الشعب الامريكي راحلومه
لانه هو الرئيس في الوقت الحاضر
والديمقراطين عارفين هذا الشيء وكل
الاحصائيات
بتبين ان الجمهوريين ممكن يفوزوا سهلا
واذا فازوا الجمهوريين مثلا اذا ربعوا الى
ربحوا مجلس الشيوخ واللي ربحوا مجلس
النواب هذا راح يوقف
بالطريق انه ما يقدر ينفذ القوانين
والاهداف تبعه وعشان هيك خائف كثير خايف
بعدين ومش عارف شو يعمل شو بيحكي للناس
والله الديمقراطيه بخطر وحريه الرائب خطر
بس كله هذا حكي فاضي يعني ما له اي اساس
نهائي ايه نادر تفضل نادر وانت تبتسم تفضل
نادر
الديمقراطيه طبيعه حقيقه في قطر يعني
الموضوع بس عندي ملاحظه انه ليست مع ترامب
يعني
هذا الانقسام والاستقطاب الحزب الموجود
بالولايات المتحده الامريكيه هو ترامب
نتيجته وليس يعني هو يعني السبب في هذه
الاستقطاب وهذا الانتساب في المجتمع
الامريكي هذا لا يمكن حسام بدا مع نهايه
السبعينيات مع يعني ظهور
جدود والمسيحيه جديده التي ظهرت في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والتعصب
بالكلام الموجود والانقسام الذي حصل بعد
الصلاه
قبل ذلك
طبعا طبعا لم يحصل على الهجوم على الكبتل
ولكن يعني بالمحص لهذا في عمليه تراكميه
هي ليست عمليه انه اذا ترامب خلال 4 سنوات
هو قسم المجتمع الامريكي بالمحصله نفترض
انه العامل الاساسي ربما يكون هو وصول
الرئيس الاسود الاول بالولايات المتحده
الامريكيه اللي هو باراك اوباما هذا كان
سبب في الذهاب الكثير من الامريكيين البيض
باتجاه اليمين والتطرف والتعصب وكره الاخر
وبالتالي اكرم كان النتيجه الطبيعيه
لمرحله تراك اوباما ثمان سنوات التي حكم
فيها براكوما همم الوصول الى الهجوم عليكم
نعم هذا كانت ضربه هذا الانقسام بالحزب
الموجود بالولايات المتحده الامريكيه همم
بالمحصله همم الديمقراطيه الامريكيه في
قطر همم الانتخابات هذه ستكون ايضا عام
ترامب همم
ان يعلن اعلان هام 15 الشهر الجاري
وبالتالي لا هناك كثير من المعطيات التي
تدفع باتجاه يعني اكبر الامريكيين بشكل او
باخر بانه الديمقراطيتهم وحتى اتحادهم في
خطر طيب هبه خطره ولا ما خطر
مع ضيفك الجمهوري ان هناك تراجع اقتصادي
كبير مع الاستاذ نادر بان بالفعل هذه
التراكمات على مر عده سنوات انما حجرها
الرئيس ترامب بدراوي لكن اي شخص امريكي
يشعر بالامان مع وجود قيم راسخه داخل
المجتمع الامريكي قيم العداله قيم
المساواه قيم حريه الراي قيام حريه
التعبير وبالتالي هذه القيم الان مع صعوبه
طيارات يمنيه متطرفه كما راينا في
الاعتداء على الهاتف في السته يناير
وان توجهات العنيفه في الجريمه سواء ضد
السود او ضد الاجانب ضد الاسيويين ضد
النساء ضد
الصينيين ضد فئات معينه داخل المجتمع
الامريكي كل هذا يرسخ
فكره العنف فكره الجريمه العنيفه عدم
التشكيك في ان هناك عدا لا يمكن ان تتحقق
امريكي فكره ان التوازن بين السلطات
الثلاثه التشريعيه والتنفيذيه
والقضائيه لم تعد موجوده وانما اصبح صراعا
بين هذه الاطراف دون ان يحقق
فائده
للمواطن الامريكي الذي يسعى فقط الى تحسين
مستوى معيشته الى
وضع المعيشه افضل الى استقرار في الاسعار
الى استقرار والارتفاع وليس الى تراجع
اقتصادي بالفعل اداره بيض المدانه فيما
يتعلق به اداره الملف الاقتصادي لكن
الجمهوريون هناك القدير مما سيكون عليه
النزاع والخلاف اذا نتحقق للجمهوريين
اغلبيه كبيره في مجلس اا الشيوخ بصفه خاصه
بعد ح- يعني المرجح ان يحصلوا على اغلبيه
في مجلس النواب لكن الخطر سيكون في مجلس
الشيوخ بما معنى انه سيكون هناك خلافات
وشد وجذب كثير خلال
وهناك قلق الى اين تسير الولايات المتحده
اذا ما كنا نشهد صراعات داخليه بهذا
المستوى من العنف ومن الاستقلال فاين
سنذهب وكيف ستكون للولايات المتحده القدره
على التاثير والدفاع عن الحريات وحقوق
الانسان والقيم الديمقراطيه الاخرى كما
كانت الامور محترئه داخل النسيج الاجتماعي
الامريكي
300 من المرشحين باسم الحزب الجمهوري يقول
صراحه لن نعترف بالنتائج في حال فاز
الديمقراطيون ما معنى مثل هذا الكلام
عندما نرى ما نرى ونسمه في ولايه اريزونا
عن نظريه المؤامره لان رفع اكثر من ولايه
انتشرت افكار تقول بان مثلا حتى الان
يقولون ترامب لم يخسر الانتخابات وهناك من
هو مقتنع حتى الان بان ترامب لم يخسر
الانتخابات يعني ما معنى هذا الكلام ان
نسمعه في الولايات المتحده اليوم
اسمع
كل هذا بعتبره من جهه الجمهوريين ومن جهه
الديمقراطيين والحكي اللي اللي الضيوف
اللي عندك بيحكوا كل هذا حكي فاضي ما
بنحكى مش مهم جوا امريكا جوا امريكا
بالوقت الحاضر الاشياء المهمه زي ما حكيت
لك
الوضع الاقتصادي والجرائم في عندنا في
امريكا هلا الجرائم زادت كثير هذه الاشياء
ال- الشخص العادي بالشارع الامريكي هذه
الاشياء اللي بيحكوا عليها والشعب
الامريكي كثير منهم بيلوموا بيلومه
الديمقراطيين للجرائم لانه بعد الحركه
العنفيه اللي كانت قبل اكم من سنه اللي
بيسموها بلاك لايف زمان كثير من المدن
اللي بيحكموها الديمقراطيين قر انه ما
يدعم البوليس او يخففوا من البوليس وما
يحترموا البوليس والجرائم هي الكاتيل
السرقه الاغتصاب كلها زادت في امريكا
والشعب العادي
والمواطن العادل الامريكي هذه الاشياء
المهمه عليه
اسمع اللي خليني اخلص الدقيقه انا الي
بحكي انه
الديمقراطيين اللي بيحكوا ان الديمقراطيه
بخطر او الجمهوريين اللي بيحكوا ان
الديمقراطيه بخطر او الجمهوريين اللي
بيحكوا ان احنا مش رايحين نعترف بالنتيجه
لان في سرقه اصوات كل هذا على بعض انا
بشوفه حكي فاضي كله بشوفه انه بس بدهم
يشجعوا بيحاولوا اخر دقيقه يعني يشجعه
شعوبهم يطلعوا صوتوا بس هيك لان يعني عاتن
الانتخابات في امريكا اللي بكتير او قد
اللي بيربح مش همم مش ال المحبوب اكثر
واحد اللي بيقدر يطلع
جماعته وهمم وزي ما انتم شوفت من وقت جورج
بوش الثاني وبعدها وبعدها في وقت ترامب
وبعد بوقت بعدين الفرق بين رئيس اللي
بيربح واللي بيفشل مش كثير اشي بسيط سوء
مهم كثير انو جماعته بيطلعوا بصوته عشان
هيك بتحكي حكي مبالغ حكي فاضي زي
الديمقراطيه بخطر او الجمهوريين بيحكوا
والله الديمقراطين بصركم اصواتنا وفي يعني
كل ما بامن فيه الحكي الشعب الامريكي اللي
اللي بيروح على الشغل كل يوم ما بيسال عن
هذا الحكي الشعب الامريكي يوم بيروح يعني
انا امبارح بعثين كمثال امبارح رحت على
السوبر ماركت اتحول الى البيت الفاتوره
طلعت 300$ هذا يعني وصار شيء مش مش يعني
احنا عائله اربعه طلعت الفاتوره 300$ كنا
يوم نروح نتحوش قبل سنه او سنتين ندفع 100
120 وهذا الشيء الناس بالجزء منها اللي
واحد بده يشتري سياره كان يعني مش يعني
اذا واحد يقدر يشتري سياره ب 20,000 كمثال
هلا بدك 50,000 تشتري سياره هذه الاشياء
اللي الشعب الامريكي بيهتم فيه عشان ايه
خايفين الديموقراطيين اما كل الحاكم
الثاني كله حكي فاضي زي ما بتحكي هذه اللي
همم اللي بيتقاطع فيها هلا كله حكي فاضي
طيب هبه هبه
غير مسبوقه في الولايات المتحده وكلنا
نعاني من ارتفاع السلع الغذائيه ورهون
العقاريه والسيارات اتفق معك تماما في هذه
لكن دعنا نرجع الى بعض الحقائق والارقام
هناك مقوله لل- همم وزير الاعلام الالماني
عندما يقول اكذب واكذب واكذب حتى تصدق
نفسك
هذه المقوله طبقها الجمهوريون والرئيس
ترمته بالدعاء التزويق بينما جاءت كل
الدعوه القضائيه التي رفعها همم
بحدوث تزوير كلها عروس من القضاء الامريكي
ولا جدال ان القضاء الامريكي لازال لا
يحتفظ بهذه النزاهه وهذه الاستقلاليه
وبالتالي رفض كل الدعوه القضائيه للرئيس
من جانب اخر هناك اشاهدنا في تحقيقات
الاعتداء على مبنى الكاتيل شهادات العديد
من المسؤولين داخل اداره ترامب نفسها بما
حدث من محاولات سمعنا
المكالمه التلفونيه للمسؤولين في جورجيا
محاوله الرئيس الحصول على 11.000 صوت حتى
يكسب الاصوات في جورجيا وبالتالي
الادعاءات في بان الانتخابات قد سرقت هو
ادعاء خاطئ ووجود عدد كبير من
الجمهوريين ومن انصار الرئيس يصدقون هذه
المقوله هذا سيعني ان انا في حاله همم
كسب الجمهوريين للكمبر السنوعيد القاره
مره اخرى في التحقيق ما اذا كان الرئيس
بيضا فاز او خساره اذا كانت انتخابات 2020
همم تم تزويرها
صحيحه كل ذلك سيرسخ حاله من انعدام الثقه
في ال ال الانتخابات الامريكيه وانعدام
مصداقيه ونزاه الانتخابات الامريكيه هذا
قد لا يكون اولويه للناشب الامريكي لكنه
يؤثر على الندى الطويل ما الذي يشجعني ان
اقوم بالتصويت وانا لا ادري كيف ستتم
العمليه وما اذا كان هناك هناك ام لا طيب
طيب نادر هناك نقطه مهمه اشاره اليها
ضعيفه ايضا هي فيما يتعلق بمستوى التطهر
يعني حسب ما نسمع دائما المعيشه هي التي
تحدد طبعا صوت الناخب الامريكي في حال تم
المساس بجانب المواطن الامريكي فانه يصوت
عكس حتى ما كان يؤمن به الان نسبه التضخم
تجاوزت ال 10% في الولايات المتحده واعتقد
انه رقم قياسي على على غرار الحديد من
الدول هذا سيكون حاسما خاصه وان بيضا لم
يكن في المستوى الذي عليه اقتصاديا ترامب
خلال سنتين الاولتين من ولاياتي
بالتاكيد بالتاكيد كما تفضلت عزيزي توفيق
الموضوع الاقتصادي او لطاقه بوكينج هو هذا
العامل الاساس يعني بالمحاصل الامريكيين
همم يعني بدي اتفق مع الاستاذ هشام مع انه
عم اهميه تم الاساءه
انه يعني الموضوع الاقتصادي لا هو عامل
اساسي هو الذي يحكم الانتخابات
الانتماء الحزبي نعم هناك في في عصبيه
حزبيه بشكل او باخر بين الامريكيين ولكن
هذه يعني نقول لا اقليه بين المواطنين
الامريكيين ولكن المواطن الامريكي العادي
زي ما حكم الاستاذ الشاب بفكر قديش عم
يدفع بالسوبر ماركت قديش عم بندفع بالجهاز
بالاخر يتصوت على هذا الاساس وهنا اثبت
الديمقراطيين التعاطي همم الاداره
الامريكيه اداره الرئيس التعاطي
يعني لم يستطيع همم ان يخطط سعر الوقود لن
يستطيع ان يخفف من التضخم اسعار الفائده
زادت في المحاوله
لتحجيم التضخم الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
كل هذا يؤثر على جيب المواطن امريكا
وبالتالي المواطن الامريكي
ما عدا همم بوش الابن وتاخيرا كان الرئاسه
في المنتخبات المصريه تذهب الى الطرف
الاخر وبالتالي الواضح انه الديمقراطيين
باتجاه الخساره في هذه الانتخابات طيب هبه
اعطاه تابع رئاسي لهذه الانتخابات لان
المتلقي من الخارج يرى دائما على الاقل
هنا في فرنسا نرى وجه بيدن وجه ترامب ودخل
على الخط وفي حين انا الامر يتعلق يعني
بكل باعضاء مجلس النواب وبثلث اعضاء مجلس
الشيوخ يعني سمعنا عن بعضهم ولكن دخول
الرئيسين الرئيس الحالي والرئيس الاسم هل
شوش على الناخب الامريكي
الى حد كبير لانه سيطره الرئيس ترامب على
الحزب الجمهوري ما زالت سيطره كبيره
وقدرته على صناعه النجوم
سواء المرشحين لمجلس النواب او مجلس
الشيوخ هي
قدره كبيره على اطفاء نوع من الشعبيه
لدرجه انه كان هناك تكه هناك
رئاسه لولا ان بعض
المستشارين نصحوه بتراجعوا عن هذا القرار
الذي
نعم سيعلن يوم الخامس عشر الاسبوع المقبل
لكن كان هناك توجع المعلن بالامس لكن
المستشارين نصحوها الا يقدم على هذه
الخطوه حتى لا يسرق البساط من تحت اقدام
او لا يسرق الاضواء من المرشحين
الجمهوريين الذين تركز هذه الانتخابات
على فكره في النهايه وجود ثلاثه رؤساء على
سبيل المثال في ولايه التي تشكل يعني
اهميه كبيره في ترجيح كفى من كافه
الحسبين داخل مجلس الشيوخ هو يدل ان لكل
رئيس بعض الشعبيه وانت راجعت شعبيه بيضا
لاستطاعات الرئيس هناك تم الاستعانه
بالرئيس اوباما بما يملكوا من شعبيه الى
حد كبير في داخل اوساط الحزب قديم
الزاويه الميول الجمهوريه
طيب كمال دائما في هذا المعنى يعني دخول
الرئيسيين على الخط وكاننا وكانه يعني شوش
على الناخب واصبحنا لا نسمع اصوات النواب
المعنيين مباشره بالانتخابات من الامور هي
محليه في التواصل مع الناخبين في كل ولايه
هذا هو الشيء دليل انك قديش الانتخابات
هذه مهمه كثير وقديش يعني من ناحيه
الجمهوريين خليني اوضح شغله واحده بغض
النظر اني انا في الحزب الجمهوري وبغذي
النظام اني انا بدي الجمهوريين يربحوا كل
منصب بامريكا انا ضد النجوم بيرش حاله
لانه بخاف انه يخرب علينا يعني احنا عندنا
مجال منيح انه نربح عندنا مجال عندنا مجال
منيح انه نربح الرئاسه وعندنا مجال منيح
انه نربح المجلس النواب والمجلس الشيوخ
يعني ترامب يوم خسر الرئاسه
يعني هم مش بس خسرها لانه بعدين طلعوا ناس
اكثر
بالحياه ما عجبهم لحد هلا ترامب ما فرجانا
كيف بده يرجع هدول الجمهوريين اللي صوتوا
ضده سو انا بتمنى كل واحد اللي بده الحزب
الجمهوري يربح بتمنى انه ترامب ما يرشح
حاله ومن ناحيه نقطه ثانيه بدي اعيد لك
اياها واعطيك مثال يوم بتحكوا ان
الديمقراطيه بخطر واشياء هيك يعني هذا
الشيء هذا الحكي مش جديد
بذكرك من وقت الانتخابات يوم بوش الثاني
غلب همم غلب جور واخذ الرئاسه بالوقت هذاك
طلعوا الناس مظاهره طلعوا الناس مظاهرات
حكوا لنا همم بوش مش رئيس المظبوط المحكمه
العليا
حطوا الحزام على الكرسي دير بالك يعني همم
زي نفس الشيء صار نفس الشيء صار يوم همم
يوم همم ترامب غلب همم غلب هيلاري هيلاري
كوينتي برده الناس طلعوا يحكوا والله في
فساد ان هيلري اخذت اصوات اكثر هذا مش
الرئيس المظبوط يعني هذا زمان قبل 20 سنه
ما كنا نسمع الحكي هذا للاسف صار هلا كل
ما واحد يخسر يحكي انه النتيجه فيها فساد
فيها كذب ويا ريت ما يحكوا هذا الحكي وانا
بحكي لك يعني همم يعني هذا الحكي اللي
بنسمعه اراهنك 90% من الشعب الامريكي ما
بيحكوا برجع على نفس الموضوع ان شعب
الامريكي 100 خوف من الجرائم ومئه خوف من
الاقتصاد السيء مش عارفين يشتروا بيوت
الفائده طلعت ال 10% من اثنين% الاشاره
للبيوت
ايه الاشياء للناس اللي بتطلع عليها وعشان
هيك يعني بيغذي النظر انه
الديمقراطيين ارقامهم اكبر من الجمهوريين
في مجال عالي انه رايحين يخسروا لايه بس
وانا عشان هيك بحكي انا خايف انه اذا
ترامب مرشح حاله انه يضيع مجال منيح لنا
انه نربح لان في كثير ناس بيكرهوه مش بس
من الجمهوريين برده من همم مش بس من
الديمقراطيين وبرده من الجمهوريين طب عجبك
الكلام
[ضحك]
كبير اول شيء هنري لما خسرت بركه نتائج
الانتخابات
اعترف بفوز وعوده
امره وقول روح شوف ادبيات العلوم السياسيه
التي تدرس في في الجامعات الامريكيه كلنا
تتحدث على انه القرار كان قرار المحكمه
الدستوريه العليا هي التي اقرت الانتخابات
وليست تسويق وبالتالي فوز جورج بوش الابن
كان مشكوك بامره بالمعنى الحقيقي بالارقام
على عكس فوز سبايدر في الانتخابات السابقه
التي لم يعترف فيها ترامب واكثر من كثير
من مرشحين اكثر من 200 مرشح موجود الان في
هذه الانتخابات سواء محليه او على مستوى
الكونغرس او على مستوى الشيوخ او مستوى
حكام البنايات ينكرون لانه بعد ان الرئيس
الامريكي
طب فارق في فرق في التعاطي في الموضوع
النقيب ممكن انه اه الديمقراطيه على ايام
جورج بوش الجوركا لا صافي تعاطي مختلف
الان نحن نتحدث عن مرشحين لمناصب حكوميه
ومن مناصب فيدراليه ينكرون انه الرئيس
الحالي هو رئيس الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وهم في مشكله بالتعاطي مع
الموضوع المحصله طيب في مشكله مع التعاتمه
الموضوع ولكن دخول ترامب على الخط يمكن ان
يساهم في دعم الحزب الجمهوري امام ان هذا
التفكك الذي تحدث عنه ضيفي ايضا في في نوع
من تردد يعني ترامب لم يعد تلك الشعبيه
سابقا له
لا لا لا
خاطئ هذا التفسير بمعنى انه صوته لترامب
في الانتخابات السابقه الرئاسيه اكثر من
صوت ولا اي رئيس امريكا في تاريخ الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه فبالتالي ال ال الكثافه
في التصويت وهذا جزء من الادبيات ادم تدرس
في العلوم السياسيه في الجامعات الامريكيه
الكثافه في التصويت غالبا هي لصالح
الجمهوريين وليس لصالح الديمقراطيين
وبالتالي 75 مليون واحد صوت لترامب سوف
يلعبون في الانتخابات القادمه 75 مليون
واحد لترامب ولكن ال 79 مليون
وبالتالي لا هناك في كثافه جمهوريه ترامب
استطاع ان يحفل هذا الاخر الافضل
بالامس نشره استطلاع للراي
الجمهوريين يخترقون السود واللاتينيه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كثافه يعني
ارقام مخيفه وبالتالي الاسود الذي يتعرض
للعنصريه يذهب باتجاه الحزب الجمهوري
وبالتالي لا في حتى
باللغه الاسبانيه يريدون التصويت التصويت
للحزبه الجمهوري بالحديث عن الولايات هبه
القدس عندما نراها هذا الخطاب المتطرف في
ولايه مثل ولايه لاريزونا وحسب ما نقرا
فان هذا طبعا جاء نتيجه كل هذه التراكمات
التي كنا سبقنا وتحدثنا عنها الامر اصبح
الان حديث ولغه وسياسه متطرفه بيتم على
الكلمه
ليس هذا فقط
لبعض الموظفين داخل مراك
غير اللائقه وهناك تهديدات بالقتل وهناك
ايضا دعاوى قضائيه قبل ان يغلط مراكز
الاقتراع ابوابه هناك دعوه قضائيه
التي وضعت خطا
في التصويت عبر البريد وبالتالي العمليه
برمتها تشهد الكثير من التشكيل وهذا يضع
مخاطر كبيره على العمليه التصويديه وعلى
الامريكي
نعم هناك تقاليد صارت عليها الولايات
المتحده
والمرشحون الرئاسيون بشكل عام والمرشحون
من كلا الاحزان هذه
ان هي احترام اا راي ان اخذ الامريكي وما
يخرج به صندوق
وبالتالي ما يحدث الان من محاولات هز هذه
الثقه هي محاولات يعني تقود العمليه
برمتها ايضا الاعتداءات وتهديد
بالاعتداء على الموظفين او على الناخبين
هي ايضا يعني منحه جديد ومظهر جديد في هذا
في هذه الانتخابات
يعني حتى الان نسمه بين نسبه المشاركه
ستكون مرتفعه جدا هذه المره لهذا تركت
السؤال ان كان يوجد خطر لان هناك لدى
الامريكيين ايضا شعور بان المجتمع في
مستوى انقسامه هو في خطره وبالتالي لابد
من التصويت وحجم التصويت ونسبه التصويت
الكبيره عاده ما تكون في صالح الجمهوريين
لا
ااا هو ااا بجوز تحكي اه بس انت خلي في
بالك يعني انه
الديمقراطين انا باعترف الجمهوري ارقامهم
اكثر من من الجمهوريين ثم مش دائما انه
اذا الارقام ارتفعت من صالح
الديمقراطيين لان في كثير انتخابات وين
صار الارقام عاليه والديمقراطين ربحوا
سوما ما بتقدر تحكي هيك 100% بس بدي احكي
لك نكته ثانيه ليش بتشوف الانكسار الشديد
اللي بيصير في امريكا دلوقت الحاضر امريكا
بتتغير وبتتغير كثير يعني هذه البلد كانت
قبل 30 سنه 80% 80% من شعبها الشعب الابيض
الشعب الاصل اوروبي وهلا البلد هذه بتتغير
بتشوف انه كل سنه بيجيها 300,000 اسبانيول
غير قانوني على البلد
عندك بيجيء جنسيات كتير سود وكل الجنسيات
هذه وكثير من البيض بده يحسوا بعنصريه
ضدهم
صار يحسوا بغض النظر انت مع هذا الحكي او
ضد هذا الحكي كثير هلا من الشعب الابيض
بحسوا ان في العنصريه قاعد بتنقلب ضدهم
وسوفي خوف في هذه البلد وبيشوفوا لنا
التكوين هذه البلد انه انه الشعب يعتمد
على حاله ما يعتمد على الدوله همم مثلا
بتشوف هلا في بتحكي مثلا من الكونجرس
الامريكي او من وقت اوباما انه بدهم يعطوا
الناس تامين ببلاش مثلا او بدهم ياخذوا
مصاري من الغني ويعطوا الفقير هذه الافكار
ما مش من تكوين هذه الدوله تكوين هذه
الدوله اساسي ان كل واحد يعتمد على حاله
ويبني هذه بشغله بتعبه
وبده يشوفوا عشان الشعوب اللي بتيجي على
امريكا بدات تتغير صار يطالبه في اشياء ما
كانوا الشعب الامريكي يطالبها بالسابق وفي
من الشعوب اللي اسست امريكا في خوف في خوف
على المستقبل اولادهم اولاده واولادهم
بيحسوا بخوف من هذه الاشياء وبيجيب هذا
بيصير وين مكان في العالم الجيل الاكبر
بيخاف من الجيل اللي اللي بيجيء وراه يعني
عندك مثلا همم
دائما كل شعوب العالم يفكروا ان الزواج
بين زلمه وامراه هلا صار مقبول في بلد زي
امريكا او من الجهه الديمقراطي
الديمقراطيين يحكوا لا الزواج بين زلمه
وزلمه مقبول وهذا اذا انت مثلا جمهوري او
اذا انت من الشعوب اللي بتامن بالعيله
باساس العيله اذا انت بتامن في الله بتشوف
ان في ضدك تهديد للتفكيرك تهديد كل كل
الوسائل الاساسيه انه عند انت كا ابو يعني
في مدارس اذا الاهل بيعلموا اولادهم ان لا
انه الزلمه مع الزلمه غلط بصير هلا في
كثير في امريكا بيحكوا والله هذا الاب
عنصري انه بيعلم انه بيعلم ابنه انه اثنين
زلام مش لازم يتجوزوا بعض سكان بيصير
تغيير كثير في امريكا وكثير من الناس همم
مين زيي انا مش مستقبلين هذا الحكي
وهذا في له دور باللي بتشوفه اللي يشوف
قاعد بيصير في البلد ليش الناس بتحس لازم
تربح لازم تربح الانتخابات ليش الجمهوريين
ميتين من الخوف اذا اذا ربح اخرى مره لانه
بيشوفوا انه بخرب في امريكا بيخرب في
تكوين امريكا وبنفس الشيء عندك زي ما
سمعنا
ال ال ال
الضيوف تبعونك بيحكوا بالعكس
الضيفه اللي عندك بتحكي شايفه خوف بالعكس
خائفه شايفه خوف ضد حريتها ايه شخصيا انا
ما يعني انا همم انا ما بشارك في رايها بس
فاهم ليش هي بتفكر هيك لان هي تكوينها
تفكير اكيد بتشوف الدنيا بيختلف على كيف
ما انا بشوف الدنيا وهذا الشيء المشكله
اللي قاعده بصير تغيير الجياد
اللي بيصير طيب نقدر تريد تتفاعل تفضل
لا اكيد يعني شوف هو في جوانب اللي حكى له
استاذ كمال فيها شو فيها نوع من الموضوعيه
بالمخصصه ولكن يعني التغيير
والموضوع التامين الصحي ما كل دول العالم
المتحضر بلاش نحكي على دولنا كلنا عالم
دبل متحضر عند التامين الصحي
لكل المواطنينها يعني ما في تامين صحي
بتدفع عليه 1500 دولار بالشهر عشان تكون
تامين صحي عندك انت
في في اشكال في يعني في مبالغه بعض
الاحياء موضوع عن الجوانب الفوارق
الاجتماعيه طبيعي طبيعي
ليس محسورا بالولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وبالتالي لا يعني في مبالغه في هذا
الموضوع نعم البيض يشعر
بالخوف على على اغلبيتهم في هذه في هذه في
هذه الدوله هم هم بيحلول عام 2040 سيكون
اقليه بالمحصل الان تم الحديث على انه
العرق البني هو العرق المسيطر وهو الذي
يحسم الانتخابات يعني بعيدا عن عن كل شيء
ممكن احنا على سبيل المثال لان يمكن بنجيب
الصوت العربي بانه نحنا عرب الصوت العربي
في بعض الولايات المتارجحه او هو صوت حاسم
يعني صحيح ربما مع الناس وحده الحال يعني
العربيه والاتفاق على مرشح واحد ولكن انا
اراد العرب في ولايه اوهايو اللي فيها
تقريبا 200 الف واحد عربي ان يجعل
ان يكون ده هذا المرشح ان كان الفعل ذلك
170 الف واحد عربي موجود في تلك الولايه
وبالتالي هذه الاقليات اصبحت قادره على
حسب نتيجه الانتخابات ولكن ما زالت غير
موحده غير غير قادر على توحيد الابيض عنده
هذا الخوف من انه هذه الاقليات ستؤثر عليه
مستقبلا ولكن يعني هذا الخوف غير مبرر
بمعنى انه يعني في في عنصريه
يعني اشك انه في عنصر بعيد ولكن يعني ربما
لديهم خوف من هذا الموضوع لانهم ممارسه
العنصريه على جميع اراقب الدنيا بالاخر
طيب هبه كيف يمكن ان نفسر ثاني بدها هذه
بدها احتسب طيب هبه يعني كيف يمكن ان نفهم
انخراط كثيرين من اصول اسبانيه او من اصول
دول تتحدث اللغه الاسبانيه واخرين من
السود يسوطون بهذه الكثافه لصالح الحزب
الجمهوري
الاقتصاد يا سيدي الفاضل الاقتصاد سوما
الاقتصاد
العامل المشتركه ما بين الناخب الابيض او
الناس الاسود او الناس الاسباني هو ما
يتعلق بمستوى المعيشه
وهذا امر يتفق عليه الجنه ايضا ارتفاع
مستويات الجريمه يزعج
جميع جميع
هذا ايضا يسعد الجميع
لا توجد دوله في العالم
لديها حدود غير مؤمنه مثل حدود الولايات
المتحده مع
الدول اللي في امريكا اللاتينيه وبالتالي
هذا شاغل ايضا يشغل الاسنان الهجره غير
الشرعيه
والمسار الى الحصول على الشرعيه او
الجنسيه الامريكيه وبالتالي لابد من تقنين
هذه الامور اعاده الملف الاقتصادي الى
الواجهه واصلاح الامور والثغرات المتعلقه
بالاداره الاقتصاديه للاداره الحاليه او
او الاداره القادمه ايضا ما يتعلق في
التشريعات التي يجب ان يضعها الكونجرس
الامريكي القادم ويضع مصلحه اخر الاميركي
اولا في قلب هذه الساعات ما يتعلق ايضا
بالفئه غير القادره او يعني الضرائب وما
يتعلق به
يعني
الطبقه المتوسطه التي تعاني اكثر معاناه
من الاثرياء وبالتالي التوجه وفرض مزيد من
من الضرائب على الاذكياء قد يفي بالغرض
الى حد النوم لكن الاداره الاقتصاديه
للملف
الاقتصادي والاقتصادي الامريكي وتشجيع
معدلات النمو والقضاء على يعني كبح جناح
التضخم هو ما يربط الناخب الاسيوي والناخذ
من اصول عربيه وناخذ من اصول الصينيه
وغيره والسود وغيرهم من الناخبين الذين
يرغبون في مستوى معيشه افضل مما هو عليه
الحال
طيب كمان قطعتك قبل ان نعطي الكلمه
للضيفين تفضل
لا خلص بكيت بدي احكي عن
الضيف تبعك اللي في تاكسيس كنت لازم نسوي
احتفال هاي اول مره اتنين اتنين فينا
اتفقوا مع بعض بس انه في ال في الاخر يعني
الست الست تحاكيت شيء همم
ههه
يعني حكت انه عن كيف ال همم الطبقه
الواسطه بتحس انه انه متضايق كماديه
وبدهم يرفعوا ضرائب هذه من هذه اشي مهم
هكذا انا معها في هذا الشيء بس هذا
الجمهوريين يعني بامنوه بامنوش انه لازم
ناخذ من الغني اللي راح درس ويشتغل والله
عطاه واللي هو بيده كده لازم ناخذ منه
ونعطي واحد ثاني
بنعلم الشخص وهو يروح يشتغل مش دور
الحكومه
[ضحك]
ان هناك
كيف اكون انا كموظفه ادفع ضرائب اكثر مما
يدفعه للياردير امريكي
لابد من يعني مستوى من العداله في هذه
الضرائب مستوى من
التخصص وليست معاقبه الاشياء المساله لا
تؤخذ بامتها او تطرى وانما نوع من التدرج
الطريق الذي
واغلاق كثافه الثرات التي يتعرض منها
الازياء والشركات العملاقه وهذا ما يمكن
ان يحقق بعد العداله الاجتماعيه في مساله
طيب دعمنا الوقت واترككم تبحثون في
الولايات المتحده عن خروف وطني اصيل له
استعداد استعدادا لولي ما في ما بينكم
باعتباره لكم احتفالا بهذا الاتفاق
لتوسلتهم الي الشكر من واشنط القدس
المديره مكتب جريده الشرق الاوسط وشكرا
لكمال ايضا محامي في الحزب الجمهوري
والشكر لنادر الغول من شيكاغو وصحافي
وباحه للجميع